regardez la joie des Saoudiens au moment
de la victoire de l'Arabie Saoudite hier
c'est jour férié
[Applaudissements]
et l'Arabie Saoudite
et que ce jour était férié
c'est incroyable c'est incroyable Gilles
c'est le prince héritier qui a demandé
au roi Salman il lui a dit c'est
fantastique il faut qu'on ferait le jour
il y a peu de jours fériés en Arabie
Saoudite mais là c'est tout les services
publics mais ça va être le tous les ans
maintenant le privé ah ben je pense
qu'ils vont reproduire tous les ans de
la Coupe du Monde effectivement
c'est ouvert les enfin gratuit les parcs
d'attractions et tout ça le gamin en
plus en Arabie Saoudite c'est genre une
icône c'est un dieu vivant là-bas parce
qu'il est genre porte-parole enfin il
défend l'Arabie Saoudite pour
l'installation là-bas des hôtels des
trucs comme ça donc c'est un ambassadeur
et donc c'est double fierté pour eux et
voilà donc c'est et il joue à domicile
au Qatar il y a des centaines de
milliers c'est là-bas c'est à côté donc
il y a des gens qui jouent vraiment à
domicile donc ils peuvent aller loin je
vous le dis moi oui
des centaines de millions d'euros sur le
pari il la côte était à 140 140 ils ont
comme c'est leur pays ils ont ils ont
misé un million de millions non bien sûr
il y a il y en a un qui a pris 30000
[Applaudissements]
en vrai je sentais que le Japon les
battlemane je l'ai dit ce midi je l'ai
dit ce midi
[Applaudissements]
j'ai tout de suite vu qu'il allait faire
une mauvaise émission non mais dès qu'il
met du pento gel il est bien sûr